yeah the context for that was that you  were talking about how it wasn't fair  for biological men to be competing with  women and you used your own example you  said I'm an athlete that's what and they  they somehow found that I still play I  play Semi-Pro right now I'm still  playing and I was I almost went pro last  year I like took volleyball to basically  the highest level that I could have and  I'm gonna tell you dudes would kill us  yeah they would kill us I can't compete  with doodoo six seven six five I can't  do [ __ ] isn't it crazy that to say that  is controversial though it shouldn't be  it's crazy I just don't want to play  with dudes call me crazy yeah and they  brought up bathrooms all day I don't  want them in the bathrooms either I'll  say that I'll say it now yeah  I'm sorry I don't I don't need that I  don't need that